i have got such a bad feelings about the
comments on this one
well that's never stopped me before
bring on the comment
[Music]
a few weeks ago i didn't know much about
don't look up that's the latest film
from the big short director adam mckay
it's a film about scientists discovering
a comet that will crash into earth and
nobody in power or in the media is
treating the issue seriously
metaphorically it's about climate change
and i would normally not bring
metaphorical analysis up this early in
the into a video like this but it's
super blunt about it and mckay has made
it absolutely clear that's what the
whole thing's about so let's just get
that out there now
i knew a couple of people who were
looking forward to it quite a bit
actually i saw one trailer it boasted an
impressive cast but
it just it didn't really grab me as
something that i was going to be up for
over two hours of i kind of shrugged it
off
but then the movie actually came out and
a
bizarre conversation around the whole
thing started
i say bizarre but honestly it's a
conversation i've seen before in
slightly different shapes
boiled down to its more basic core
components
a lot of people including many critics
didn't like the movie and the filmmaker
and people who did like the movie pushed
back
not by defending the film but uh
attacking the people who didn't like it
like i said i've seen this before
examples from the last few years would
include joker the last jedi batman v
superman dawn of justice that last one
uh just to take it as a case study real
quick the people who enjoyed that film
were very fond of accusing people who
did not enjoy it of everything from
being too stupid to get it to being paid
shills for disney in order to
artificially boost the rival marvel
cinematic universe i personally got
accused of that second one
more than a few times
in other words
from the perspective of these people
it's not acceptable
that some folks just have a different
assessment of the work or just have
different tastes there has to be
something actually wrong with them that
they didn't like this
now what made this one a little bit
different from the others i cited is
that generally when i've seen this
happen it's within existing fandoms
usually a long existing fandom divides
but don't look up is a new film it
doesn't have an existing fandom well i
mean the the actors the director they do
to some degree but generally that
wouldn't give rise to something like
this
instead we've seen
you know it's actually not a clean
political divide though i'm sure some
people are going to paint it as one see
there's basically people who don't like
the film for whatever reason maybe they
view the climate messaging as flawed or
blunt maybe they view the satire as
onenote or ineffective the film having
an unearned sense of smug superiority
gets cited maybe it's too long or
dragged out or maybe they feel it's just
not very good on the basics of
filmmaking
and then there's mckay
primarily but also others who have put
forth the argument that anyone who
doesn't like the movie doesn't believe
in climate change
yeah he does in fact appear to be saying
that taste cannot be a factor in this
you either like the movie or your
climate change denier
so after that lovely tweet mckay's
twitter has basically become nothing but
a repository of retweets of anybody
praising the film and it's stayed that
way for a few weeks now so
oh okay
let's try and parse this whole mess
firstly can we just dispel the idea that
if you don't like a thing it must be
because you disagree with its political
or philosophical stances
sometimes things just work for whatever
reason and sometimes things just don't
work for you sometimes they're just bad
is this a bad movie
oh okay look the thing is i've been in
this conversation from both sides of
this perspective because not only are
there films that i agree with what
they're trying to say but i also don't
like them but vice versa there are films
i fundamentally disagree with in terms
of their core messaging but i still
enjoy them for instance of that second i
really like the movie 300.
i absolutely do not agree with the core
positions and the messaging at the heart
of the movie but i still really like it
i like the movie on the flip side of
that a few years ago doctor who aired
the episode orphan 55. it's an episode
with a very blunt environmental message
and a dire warning to humanity both of
which i wholeheartedly agree with
but it's still a really bad episode
agreeing with the position that a piece
of art is taking doesn't automatically
mean someone will like it and
disagreeing with it won't automatically
mean that somebody will hate it
oh those can be factors i'm not saying
they're not in the mix at all a film
aligning or failing to align with your
beliefs might incline you toward liking
or not liking it respectively but it's
not the sole determining factor for most
people
and look
i will be one of the first people to
tell you that every single piece of art
is inherently political so i'm not
trying to strip the politics out of the
equation but the thing is
art isn't
only political
because you still have to execute the
idea properly and if people think you
fail at that it's not an inherently
political disagreement for them to say
so
okay so
did the movie fail
i said oh
well
whenever a piece of media is going to be
critically viewed and assessed there are
honestly a ton of things to take into
consideration many of which are medium
specific for instance music score is a
factor in film but not in comic books
while comic books have to worry about
text box formatting films generally do
not
but ultimately no matter what the medium
is no matter what shape the art takes
there are two core questions that we can
always ask when assessing a piece of art
the first is does it succeed at what
it's set out to do
now for the purposes of this
conversation
we're going to set aside the fact that
part of what any film sets out to do is
turn a profit because we're gonna be
talking about what it sets out to do
artistically for the time being we are
going to ignore what it's set out to do
commercially because that's the same in
every case
now this is always a key question and
keep in mind the answer is rarely
actually straight up binary yes or no
especially in an art form as
collaborative and with as many moving
parts as film specific elements or
performances or the cinematography
choices anything might succeed or fail
on an individual basis but when looked
at as a whole
does the film accomplish what it sets
out to do
in the case of don't look up it sets out
to use the fictional comet to viciously
satirize the current state of climate
disaster and the mishandling of that in
the real world precisely how
successfully it did that
is a bit subjective but for the purposes
of this discussion at this point i'm
going to err on the side of yeah i did
what it set out to do at least for now
but even if we accept that that's not
the end of the conversation though a
frustratingly large number of people
have a tendency to act like it is anyway
the second question that always needs to
be asked is the thing it set out to do
a thing worth doing
now
on the surface
this should be a clear cut yes in the
case of this movie because
climate change is real humans are
contributing to it and we collectively
are failing at changing the course of it
but
that's the message
what is this film intending to do with
that message who is it for and this
is where i have to actually deal with
the question i've been kind of putting
off for a bit
not really no
[Music]
okay okay okay okay i know i can't
actually get away with that i'd like to
honestly i'd hope to be able to make a
video and just focus it on the
conversation around the film and not
have to actually watch the thing
except i knew that if i didn't that
would ultimately be wheeled against me
and it would derail the entire exercise
so i did watch it and
no it's it's not very good i'm not going
to go through all of my issues because
i'm trying very hard not to have this be
a review in a pretentious sweater
but here's the brief summation
i personally
found the satire to be smug in a way
that was compounded by how long scenes
were drawn out after having already made
their points on top of how repetitive
the film is over its two-hour plus run
time now i know my distaste for that is
a personal taste thing i honestly find
idiocracy to be annoyingly smug though
that at least had the decency to be
under 90 minutes plus
let's be honest about it the newsroom
which is a show not above some
insufferable smugness of its own
that show made the same point in four
minutes and it hit it much harder for
its succinctness so what can we do to
reverse this well there's a lot we could
do good for 20 years ago or even 10
years ago but now
no you sound like you're saying it's
hopeless
yeah
are you going to get in trouble for
saying this publicly
who cares i personally didn't find the
comedy very funny though
i rarely find mckay's films funny and
that's going all the way back to
anchorman so clearly the man and i have
never been on the same page comedy wise
these were honestly
big issues for me
but also as i've already admitted pretty
subjective ones at the end of the day
some folks might not have found it smug
or maybe the smugness didn't bother them
even if they did sense it was there some
folks may have found the comedy moments
to be actually funny or even hilarious
and all of that is fair
less subjective though is the scatter
shot approach it takes to its targets
and the fact that the metaphor the
entire film is based on is flawed on
premise
so
let's talk about how metaphors work at
their best the key fundamental details
have to map on from the real world topic
to the metaphorical example but not
every single detail has to have a
precise equivalent so for instance the
things that the characters in don't look
up try to do in order to stop the
comment aren't the same things that we
do in reality to battle climate change
or that we should be doing we can't try
and blast climate change off course with
a nuclear bomb
but differences like that don't really
matter
what matters is that in both cases these
are things people can and should be
doing but are stalling at or are
outright failing to do them at all and
the major players are the same
politicians scientists tech moguls
resource hoarders and public opinion
those are all in play in both cases so
the metaphor still works on that level
where it doesn't work though is in the
fact that the comet was going to show up
and kill the planet regardless of the
actions of people
see
while a certain amount of climate shift
is natural
the reason we're in such dire straits is
because human society has accelerated
and exacerbated the problem
exponentially it would never have gotten
this bad without our actions but the
comet wasn't going to be a near miss but
for the actions of man it was a force of
nature that was always coming
now
that is in its own way a kind of
existential threat because
frankly speaking the fact that this
planet is habitable at all is a miracle
and the number of things that could
literally drop out of the sky and end it
all is incalculable
and that is terrifying
but it's not the same kind of terrifying
that a problem we actively brought upon
ourselves is
it's not the same
the metaphor doesn't map on
and when you use an act of god as a
metaphor for a man-made problem it
completely ignores how we even got here
in the first place and that matters to
the real life issue you are trying to
make a commentary on
now
admittedly the metaphor starts working
better
after about the halfway mark at which
point the initial cause of the problem
actually becomes irrelevant because at
that point the people in charge aren't
addressing it regardless of how we got
there and they're failing to do so for
stupid and short-sighted reasons and
that maps on to the reality depressingly
well but that's still the entire first
half of the movie predicated on a faulty
premise before it gets to the point
where it actually starts working but by
the time that core metaphor starts
functioning about halfway through the
way that it should have been from the
very start by that point the film has
acquired such a laundry list of things
it's also satirizing that it can't
skewer any of them with any real depth
or sharpness the first half of the film
has the metaphor problem but it was at
least well focused on the issues of the
people in charge not taking the problem
on board and the double-edged swords
that are mass media and social media
where everybody can be reached but even
if you only speak truth you have to sell
it right or else nobody listens but then
by the time the metaphor issues got
sorted out and it was mapping on the way
it should have been from the first place
again at about the halfway mark by that
point the film is also taking on
disaffected youth politicizing of
scientific issues tech sector ceos who
are also pulling triple duty as
stand-ins for fossil fuel pushers and
big money political donors the hero
worship of aging figures with outdated
perceptions of the world mob mentality
and i think the corrupting influence of
the system
like i'm honestly not sure what leonardo
dicaprio's character of randall and his
whole
being taken in briefly by the bs coming
from the top and then cheating on his
wife is meant to be addressing
is climate scientist secretly boning
news anchors a big issue that i don't
know about
and what i really don't get is that he
basically has the exact same what is
wrong with you people breakdown that
jennifer lawrence's character of kate
had 40 minutes before that
which i assume happened because i think
she's supposed to represent young people
being the most vocal about the problem
but also the first to be ignored but
then when randall has his own near
identical breakdown some time later
there's still 50 minutes left in the
damn movie what was the point
that specific plot threat aside i do get
what the movie's going for with most of
this and even hits some of its targets
but it's aiming at too much with this
bloated run time to try and fit it all
in
these end up being shallow digs by the
time the credits actually roll
but in the end even these points i'm
making
there's still some subjectivity to this
so
in order to talk about why i feel the
movie fails on the most objective
measure that i'm able to
we need to talk about the movie's goals
in more depth than when i brought it up
before
so in order to nail down why i feel
comfortable saying that this movie
failed we need to talk about what it was
actually trying to accomplish as a film
beyond
just the message that it was intending
to convey which as i said i do think it
conveys that message but that's not the
only thing at play in what it's trying
to accomplish
now on that issue i want to circle back
to those bits of praise that mckay has
been retweeting endlessly now for weeks
because
i'm not going to just dismiss those well
i'll point out that endlessly retweeting
praise for your work while insulting or
demonizing any criticism is at best just
kind of tacky but i don't want to
dismiss those actual praises some people
genuinely connected with this film and
if mckay's retweets are any indication
most of the people who connected with it
the hardest are environmentalists and
climate researchers and they say the
film captures the madness they've been
dealing with for decades the sense of
sounding every alarm they can while
being brushed off and ignored and i can
understand that that makes total sense
as a way to connect to this film
but was that the goal to validate the
existing feelings of people who already
hold these positions
or was it trying to signal boost the
issue through satire to reach as many
people as possible i honestly don't know
which it was but i'm going to look at
both options
because if the intent was to reach the
widest possible audience and get them to
think about climate change in a way that
they hadn't before and hopefully realize
the seriousness of the issue in a way
they didn't previously
well it failed at that
lots of people have been actively turned
off by this movie i mean just assume for
the moment that it was never gonna reach
outright climate deniers so we're gonna
ignore that but it didn't appear to
reach the people who are more on the
fence or who maybe believe that climate
change is a problem but don't appreciate
the scope and scale of it even people
who agree with the positions of the film
such as myself
were turned off so if the goal was
spreading the message to those who need
to hear it it failed
so
what if that wasn't the goal
what if its intention was in fact to
channel and validate the frustrations of
those who understand how big this
problem is
what if it is in fact meant
to preach to the choir
now that phrase preaching to the choir
is generally used in a derogatory way
you're talking to people who already
agree with you so
you're not convincing anybody new and
arguably
not accomplishing much if anything at
all
but you know what
sometimes there is value in preaching to
the choir sometimes the choir needs
validation
and to not feel like they're being
ignored while you go out and preach to
people who aren't ever going to listen
to you anyways
to put it into a context that i talk
about fairly regularly
as a queer person i feel
vital
validation in media designed to speak to
me about my queer experiences it's part
of why representation matters to see
yourself reflected in the art is a
reminder that you're not alone that you
are seeing and if this gave climate
scientists the same kind of somebody
finally gets it feeling that i got when
i watched tracy's story uh link up there
for what that is and why it mattered to
me i don't have time to get into it here
but if that's what happened
i'm happy for them and i wouldn't want
to take that away from them
except
if this film's goal
was to preach to the choir
then its goal and its message are
incompatible
because the film is about how people who
need to wake up and pay attention aren't
doing it but if the film is in fact
aimed only at the people who are already
paying attention then it's an inherent
failure at the thing
it's saying should be happening
you can't make a film designed to only
appeal to the people who already agree
with you
when your message is at least in part
this is important for
everyone to understand
so
as far as i'm concerned don't look up
is a failure
either it tried to reach as wide an
audience as possible and instead
alienated them or
it aimed at a niche audience in which
case it's self-defeating on its own
merits because the message is in
contradiction to that goal and in either
case
adam mckay implying anyone who didn't
like the movie as a climate change to
deny her sure as hell didn't help
look
if you like this movie that's fine
going into this i admittedly had a
number of things working against my odds
of ever liking it mckay is a director
rarely does it for me i think the big
short is the only one of his movies i
ever liked and frankly i've just liked
almost every end of the world movie i've
ever seen i didn't like melancholia i
didn't like heaven in the woods i didn't
like beneath the planet of the apes oh
ah crap uh spoiler is on those second
two sorry
not really sorry i think the only one i
did like
was doctor strange love and the reason
that worked was because it was precisely
focused on its satirical targets not
only is it taking laser accurate shots
at the military and political minds who
created the entire nuclear arms race
mess
it also doesn't leave their perspective
as far as the movie is concerned this is
what the world is so rather than taking
middling shots at so many targets it
instead unloads a tactical nuclear
strike on the targets it has and hits
them dead on in a way that this film
[Music]
didn't not for me anyway look i agree
with don't look up's overall points but
it doesn't get a pass for that i'm not
going to override my sense of taste and
enjoyment and praise a work i don't like
just because it lines up with my beliefs
and
mr mckay
look
if people thought the movie had a sense
of smugness before the director started
going anyone who doesn't like my work is
an idiot
yeah you didn't help you escalated the
problem seriously dude what the hell
all right
that's enough out of me
how much do you hate me now that i've
talked about this i don't know let's
find out put your thoughts down in the
comments
even if you think i am dead wrong about
this movie or the conversation around it
please be polite i don't delete comments
for disagreeing with me i do delete them
for being insulting to me the creators
of the works i talk about or to other
commenters so don't do that because i'll
delete your comments and probably block
you from being able to comment further
in the future so just be polite it's not
that hard
so
with all that said i do want to hear
what people think about this what they
thought of the movie the situation the
conversation the topic in general
let's hear it and uh if you liked this
video
hopefully some people did
well if you did you want to support what
i do there's a patreon up there also
link in the description plus links to
all my other social media and various
other projects down there from podcasts
to novels being available to
uh p.o box and
twitch all that stuff
no big pressure on any of it though
because
at the end of the day my friends
you are the council i'm just running the
meeting
and until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
thanks for sticking around into the
credits none of this would have been
possible without my patreon supporters
in particular i want to thank robin
powell tracy scrabbit vincent paul
partolucci robin moore jayla gourle and
bookworm
thanks for keeping this going and to
everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]